[Applause]
- Jeff late mark Tucker christen boggle
and John Lynch for their contributions
to the design and architecture of the
Houdini visual effects an animation
system the Academy presents a scientific
and engineering award please join me on
the stand
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you sir Patrick
Houdini has helped many superhero movies
come to life
mayhem intergalactic destruction and all
but to us the superheroes have always
been the visual effects artists with
their incredible talent and their
equally incredible drive for physical
realism and art direct ability those two
always intertwined building technology
for them has been a privilege and a
blast and often times literally so and
to be recognized by the Academy it's
just the the absolute honor thank you
the four of us on stage today Oh much of
our presence here to the incredible
talent and also the incredible effort
that our entire R&D team have put in our
software ever since just a handful of us
started at 25 years ago also on a
personal note I owe my CG addiction to
the mathematical beauty of splines
anyone remember those and I have my my
family my wife Simona and my daughter
Naomi to thank for the beauty of
everything else thank you
I'd like to thank my wife Kaitlyn and my
daughter Sophie for helping me separate
the real from the unreal in this world
I'd like to also thank my family
Laura Kayleigh and Alex for giving
meaning to the other half of my life
thank you
I just like to thank my colleagues its
side effects my wife Carol and my
daughters Avery and Hayden for
supporting me in this work and going to
the movies with me and seeing our
software in action and reminding me this
work and life can be a lot of fun thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]